i'm so excited um i'm not gonna lie this
show
i've been wanting to get on the rooftops
and scream
about it i've been wanting to skywrite
about this show because i feel at least
from my perspective and experience it's
been very unique it's not like other
shows
the co-hosts of queer eye are getting me
ready for an actual first date
yep
yep um
his name is sam he's a chef and we met
on an actual dating app
and um so not only are you gonna see
jonathan and tan and bobby and anthony
get me ready it's like every person's
fantasy
it's just fun and we break it down and
this is real talk so take a look
hi
hi
welcome to the jv and hair salon that
pop up at the drew barrymore showa
you are so stunning birthday in the
morning what am i supposed to do well
robin did do some makeup on me you're
going on a first date here i'm really
obsessed with that story first of all i
was so excited to do this with you guys
and then we came up with this concept
because i met this guy on the dating app
and he was the most normal person about
the process like hi
it's nice to see you he's hot too
because i saw a picture i haven't seen a
picture of him in so long oh no he's
cute i i i looked that's good and he was
so nice and normal and not evasive but
he was like you're in la right and i was
like no i live in new york oh and then i
was like oh that doesn't feel very
exciting on zoom but then i was like
what's up
there's so many things about this that i
can't imagine being a heterosexual first
of all second of all going on a date
with drew barrymore like i just can't
imagine like you're so gorgeous
okay so first things first let's talk
about your hair let's not do something
crazy different that you wouldn't
normally do because i think it's hard to
feel a little bit confident yeah i just
think we should do like sexy hair
this is our insta recovery serum i'm
really into practicing safe heat styling
so i'm just going to come in and i'm
just going to protect your ends before i
put heat to them watch this watch this
i'm just going to put this on the side
of the toast okay this is the most
fascinating tutorial i'm so excited
right now oh good
oh my god this is why
we use heat protectant can you stand
that america this is what's happening
for america
when we don't use heat protectant okay
[Music]
oh wait can i just tell you i got to be
like fully honest yes for the past like
three minutes i've been inundated with
an intrusive thought of when you are an
ever after this literally like changed
my entire formative life it also kind of
made me want to be a hairdresser like
one of the first times i was like ooh
i'm obsessed
when you step onto that stage and you
say just breathe breathe
[Music]
okay so you see i'm just like holding it
before i let it set uh-huh just like
gently like letting it cool for a second
yeah because then the curl will like
last better no i love it i'm picking up
every single thing you're doing
i'm so excited to be getting my hair
done by you jonathan this is such an
honor and so much fun oh my it's too
much fun
okay i'm just gonna break up these waves
oh my god jonathan i am not blowing
smoke i really love my hair thank you
pretty well oh my god i feel so pretty i
love it do you love it i love it thank
you for letting me do it oh my god
jonathan
hello my love
i'm so excited to see you i'm so excited
you already look so cute this is how i
roll into work knowing that i'm going to
get dressed in beautiful clothes so i
don't even think about what i look like
i'm almost rolling in and what i sleep
in but do you feel good in it no
my friends go don't you dare wear your
sweatpants on a date never
never
never well i think there's a version of
you but like the best version of you you
know our show which means we're not
turning anyone into somebody they're not
i know just how well polishing you up
we're just saying okay this is who you
are let's find the best version of that
you're going to go on a date with me so
we don't want to trick him no we don't
want to trick anyone that's what i
always tell my friends i don't want to
trick them i'm like i don't get dressed
up every day except for for work
so i always want to be myself yeah but
the best version of ourselves
oh my god i know where do you love it
what do you think i already love it
should we add jewelry
oh that's so pretty let's do that i also
hear you love a flower
so here's the thing you're not going to
see the bottom half because it's a zoom
however
the top part looks like you made an
effort but all it is is a
a t-shirt and a sweater
[Music]
oh my gosh do i look they're as
comfortable as gene crazy
this feels right the zoom
so
we could go
did we nail it is this the look come on
sam we're going on a date great
you've heard me say this on the show but
i'm just going to say this as my only
advice you're putting clothes on anyway
you may as well make them beautiful
you're putting in the effort of putting
clothes on your body don't you want to
feel good in those what's the point of
putting sweatpants on a t-shirt and if
you're not feeling great about it
you may as well just put that thing on
that you really like i feel like this is
the quintessential oprah aha light bulb
moment
this does feel very me
but not i also love it i bet i don't
feel like it looks psycho the old
necklace is picking up the little gold
hearts oh we're just gonna do a bunch of
gold you know what i have a new theory
about accessories
accessories say i meant to leave the
house i chose to style it this way yes
and so if you feel good in a sweatshirt
and jeans wear this you look gorgeous
i feel so myself good i
don't feel like the me that came in
showing you the epitome of my worst yes
but
i think
this just feels really good and
i like the way i look and in the best
way ever i'm not thinking about it good
that's it we nailed it thank you i love
you
thank you jonathan and tan how about
that jonathan he is just so funny
and sweet
and tan is just such a lovely person
[Music]